it all comes down to this
three
two
one
[Music]
guess what time it is underrated the
only show that allows professional
athletes to improve their ratings in
their favorite video games and today
michael porter jr and we're gonna go to
r2k gamer davis to see how he stacks up
in the game
we've been knew mike reported junior
could shoot all right but the finishing
is what's severely underrated in the
last season i really think he's shown
that he can finish well at the paint we
need to see that reflected in 2k the
small 40 is an extremely versatile
position not only do you need to be able
to shoot but you need to be able to
finish over people dunk on
[Music]
i hear that you believe you deserve a
badge for contact finishing yeah driving
to the lane taking the bump and
finishing the basket yeah and you don't
have one right contact finishing that's
definitely something i want to get up in
my 2k ready if you had an issue with not
having badges or ratings who would you
normally hit up like you got to hit up
ronnie well guess what
ronnie
[Applause]
ah
ronnie is in the middle
okay
finishing through contact yep can we
talk about how important a badge is to a
player in the game yeah we had a
separated contact finisher for dunking
and contact finisher for layups and we
felt like that was duplicative so now we
have it for one that's what we're
playing here for that's what we're here
for we're gonna find out whether he can
contact phoenix i need you to know this
is a big deal yeah you got the spotlight
on you you can prove it out i want to
see i want to see it through yes brother
now
if you don't do well
there is the risk that you go down and i
need my rating that's not going to
happen okay you're confident you're
going up okay today
here's how this is going to work we got
ronnie on the block first up he's got
these paddles there's gonna be five
drives that you have to do you gotta
make at least four but it's gonna get
harder every time okay are you ready i'm
ready okay
be gentle
three
two
one
go
a lot of contact
that was an add-on
in the face we're advancing past the
sticks bringing the balls
are you ready i'm ready three
two
one
contact finishes if one was good
two is better
let's bring them both out
three
two
i don't think there's one gonna stop you
he got an animal in him i mean he is
ferocious though he's three for three
he's going for four for four mpj in
three
two
one go
hey huh
[Music]
well what happened
you know what
i went with the one hand around the rim
you got to go with two made a mistake he
adapts he learns he adjusts
it all comes down to this michael porter
jr three for four has to go four for
five to get the bronze badge we now have
three balls
three
two
one
no
no
it was right there it was in
it was in
[Music]
it was right there the balls were
bouncing
it's right there man you seem impressed
though yeah i was impressed i mean he he
got he got where he needed to go that's
all that matters with that being said
yes
are you willing to throw a badge he
didn't did the 80 but i feel like you're
impressed i feel very confident that he
will get he will get that badge i think
he deserves it for sure your level of
excitement and joy where are we at right
now very excited you know sometimes you
get hacked sometimes you're not gonna
finish every layup you might go the free
throw line i feel like i got fouled on
that last place that's that's probably
true
so now we know mike reporter junior can
finish in the paint but now i want to
see him in 2k being able to you know hit
him with a jab ship get to the paint and
shoot up a nice little floater
teardropper is the badge we're going to
need to see that is the best that if
someone's in the pan you want to shoot a
little florida over top easy buckets
right there
[Music]
i heard you saying earlier that nobody
has a better teardrop than you no doubt
because it's the in-between game you
know sometimes
when you come off a pick-and-roll or
whatever there's a lot of big guys down
here you might want to shoot the
in-between little floater get it easy
too it's going to be hard again you've
got to hit a floater over each of our
obstacles miss three floaters you don't
get the teardrop badge let's see if he
can do it
all right easy one up first some small
trees
in three
two
one
go
oh
okay that's a strike that's a strike we
get three okay we got three of them a
little more speed
[Music]
okay okay okay
all right it would have been tough to
get out of there if you had missed both
of those all right we are going to now
upgrade it
from the trees to the t-rex
dinosaur has entered the building is
there a defender in the nba that has
this profile remind you of you know what
i think this reminds me more like taco
fall it's probably about seven five
seven six you got that height all right
so you got one strike
let's get this done on the first try
let's do it three
two one go
[Music]
you know what when i got up to the to
the t-rex i couldn't even see my target
so i had to jump up a little bit float
it up there well this one's gonna be
harder
one strike two baskets
and it all comes down to this
oh
now
all the way up there
this is a 14 foot
defender okay do you see that he touched
the bottom of the shoes that's when you
know it's serious it's real now for an
nba 2k badge
three
two
one
the height oh
he is online yeah you look good
i play good under pressure my last
strike this is it let's get it
for a badge michael porter all comes
down to this
three
two
one
[Music]
give that man a bath impressive all
right
with one strength to spare
congratulations how did that feel felt
great now give me my bag
give me my bag
all right just take me through what that
felt like and it felt more realistic
than uh than i thought you know i got up
here saw the taller defender a lot of
times guys are jumping so high you got
to get it up so that's what i did and it
dropped did we get two badges today i
feel pretty good about it i you know i
don't think we can deny him any of those
badges as much as i want to
and now's my favorite question i get to
ask
ronnie 2k
is michael porter jr underrated i guess
so i mean we've missed two badges
yes yeah how does it feel to be the
proud owner of two new badges in nba 2k
feels good man i'm gonna start playing
with my player more because i'm gonna
stop smoking layups smoking floaters
michael porter jr officially underrated
i'm proud
[Music]
you